[Applause]
[Music]
the rest of those festivals with
arrested precedent for the rest oh I
have a lot of problems with you people
and now you're going to hear about it
people who drink coffee through a straw
I hope you dive from the wax and the
plastic that melts to be stuck after
you're done now why do men say they're
pregnant was their wives the ladies
doing all the work why are you trying to
take some of the credit any time I'm on
the airplane and the brothers staring at
the seat in front of them and there's no
TV on the seat back you leave that
brother alone there might not be
anything worse than people who chew at
their mouths open either close your
mouth when you chew or leave your mouth
wide open and don't chew it all and
throw the food into your throat no soup
for them
[Music]
you